Here are my top three principles that guide me in doing business.
One, get personal with your customers.
With every transaction, your customer is giving you power,...
...so don't take that power for granted.
We get to know our customers on a personal level...
...because we take the time to really listen.
Building that kind of relationship creates an authentic,...
...reciprocal understanding between brand and customers.
Two, don't be afraid to break the rules.
So my point is, don't be afraid to try things differently.
Don't expect the same rules to apply to your small business...
...as I do to Fortune 500 companies.
Embrace what makes you you and make it a part of your strategy...
...rather than following the same old playbook...
...that's out there for everyone to see.
Three, make your intuition your BFF.
Running a business is noisy and demanding.
It's important to know who you are and who you are not.
That means knowing when to say no.
For me, that's meant turning down outside capital.
Yeah, that extra cash flow would have been amazing,...
...but investors would want to maximize profits...
...and, in turn, compromise the community...
...and culture aspects of what we stand for.
And for me, that's non-negotiable.
At the end of the day, you have to be grateful.
No one has to work for you and no one has to be your customer.
People have choices,...
...so remember to appreciate every employee effort and every sale.